previously on TV sentence mix did oh
yeah and I accidentally stomped on him
on the bridge a minute 36 seconds eeem
song this therapist is opted for a
titillating piece of waiting room art
that it is sure to start a council
worthy conversation between a person's
psyche and reproductive parts have a
seat I'm no mob boss but if I were I'd
want to sit facing the door so I
couldn't be caught unawares my
understanding from dr. cusimano your
family physician is that you collapsed
I'm not sure if I should send this show
or the movie analyzed this for the weird
mobsters in therapy pop culture deluge
of 1998 but since the show came out
three months earlier this could just be
a sin for making me think of Dante's
Peak and volcano how are you feeling now
I'm feeling very beige on beige on beige
look it's impossible for me to talk to a
psychiatrist any thoughts at all on why
you blacked out man this relationship
between Tony and dr. Melfi is one of the
show's best the counseling sessions are
a stroke of genius on the creators part
into a great job of differentiating this
show from all the other gangster dramas
out there glad they won't do something
stupid down the road and create a will
they or won't they subplot for a series
of episodes I've never understood
families who consume milk out of a jug
like this well I spent the time pouring
milk out of one jug into another job and
what happens if all this milk isn't
consumed during breakfast does it get
poured back into the first job how do
you stay so skinny mrs. soprano
him those Ducks the stress of your
husband feeding ducks causes so much
anxiety that your body burns enough
calories to keep your weight off your
thinking entirely too much about mr.
acid his Ducks chill gain a fear look
they're trying to fly kids last year
Aspen I saw Skeet always even in 1998
trying to make skeet over it's a thing
seems data and you thought David Harbor
invented sexy ponch dad bought meat mob
Bob I don't know where this story is
going me either dr. nathie has clearly
graduated from the Rickon stark school
of running away from things I mean I've
never been chased by monsters but if I
were I wouldn't run along the road where
the car could easily follow I've run
into a building with witnesses and
access to a phone to call for help
how did Christopher get here the last
time we saw him he was chasing down the
car looking injured the only way he kept
up with the car chase as if he's on
drugs or a secret superhero I'll give
one guess as to which is the likely
answer I really want to take this moment
seriously but the punch sounds are too
much $3,000 for a headlight if you were
to get a headlight replaced on a Lexus
in 2019 it's an average cost of $385
kind of car repair inflation was going
on in 1998 look at those gerbil bites on
Tony's hand what you think he got those
from punching Mahaffey forget about it
and this is oddly enough how Silvio
decides to use uncle jr. whacking [ __ ]
malanga as the title for his upcoming
strip club amateur night uncle juniors
my father's brother good guy just
getting old cranky you should take me to
Yankee games when I was a kid uncle jr.
is a bad guy for many reasons and
subjecting poor innocent children to the
Yankees puts him over the edge as the
most horrible person on this show you
just speak Tonko jr. Bobby okay
he respects you he'll listen to you Tony
really think having his mother speak to
jr. will help the situation and he
hasn't even explained what uncle jr. is
going to do to [ __ ] malanga so she
doesn't even know what to talk to him
about got a brain tumor
well we're gonna find out what a bedside
manner I mean carriages that's not the
first time Nurse Jackie would have a
poor review from a patient the pig heads
have been there the entire time and
Christopher is very familiar with this
space so why is he acting surprised that
these little piggies went to the market
Tony watches Godfather to all the time
Tony prefers to not want to be fair that
makes more sense as a cause for a panic
attack then Ducks lungs out I had a
semester and a half of college so I
understand Freud 1998 version of reading
a Wikipedia article and knowing
everything about something Tony has
stormed out and dr. Melfi strikes this
pose as a self-proclaimed body posture
expert I can tell you two things one
she's unhealthily obsessed with this
statue in her waiting room and two this
pose is one of self-confidence and power
but more importantly it allows her to
check her incredibly potent Bo based on
how they were swinging the body in a
level instead of upward motion what did
they think would happen also the
situation went from murder cover-up to
return of the zombie how else did it set
up on his own brains
five full seconds pass from the time
Toni passes out till someone moves suzay
this family dysfunction is depressing
enough for me to add it to the agenda
for my next therapy session you have any
qualms about how you actually make a
living a question asked to cinemasins
staff here we go it comes to Prozac
oddly enough here comes the Prozac was
what my college girlfriend would say to
me right before pin pocketing out of the
money a man does not have the money we
ran the man over with the car T himself
getting hit by a car does not mean you
instantly have money if it did nobody
would yell hey I'm walking here we leap
into traffic and get paid a little [ __ ]
you think he's gonna a big [ __ ] my
[ __ ] I'm not saying there isn't some
good writing going on here however I do
feel like when it's Tony's crew talking
David chase worked with a gangster
dialect dictionary and a pair of 12
sided dice Sandrine they were drinks on
house honor first off something tells me
Tony has never had to pay for anyways so
not sure why this announcement is made
but what would even be the special
occasion I'm having to figure out a way
to make a murder take place at a
different location isn't that every day
in the waste management disposal
business
I'm not going going where every year on
this date since you were Eddie bitty you
know what I regret asking skip to tell
you the truth I felt it was dumb since I
was eight teenager has outgrown childish
thing like tea parties with her mother
but the dolls will remain to dry her
angsty hormonal tears without judgment
- things are grating on my nerves here
that outdated calendar on the wall and
the ridiculous notion that a restaurant
makes their staff use strips of tape to
hang their tickets do you know how
inefficient that is I'm trying not to be
cynical and failing because the only
explanation for the scabs on my hafiz
forehead is that he purposely made nice
with a weed eater in the woodshed
to injure himself beyond the broken leg
cynics got a cynic I guess I get Tony is
trying to help but even if he gets
already out of town for a few weeks that
doesn't mean he'll shut the restaurant
down it could have his assistant manager
or someone else run it while he's gone
and then the hit would still happen and
Artie would still be out of business to
be fair this is probably very similar
areas to where the Hat has been when it
was JFK's well you think I was Hannibal
lecture before something Hannibal Lecter
mothers and then
on us she'll come back who knew Miley
Cyrus gets most of her song ideas from
The Sopranos weirdly that actually makes
sense
sports spirits what do you guys want
perfection only if you're going to turn
this into a tremors movie which for the
record I fully endorse I had a dream
last night my bellybutton was a Phillips
head screw and when I get it unscrewed
my penis falls off I pick it up though
I'm holding it up and this bird swoops
down grabs and it's beak show has time
for this sort of birds last week on
cable you'd think maybe that planted the
idea I mean that scene in the birds
where Rod Taylor gets his bitten off
does stick with you there's something
I'll tell him we torched the restaurant
it's the best solution lying
everything's gonna be all right from
here on in come on oh thank god because
if [ __ ] were to die and Tony was to get
shot by his own mother that would be
really horrible or if Tony killed
Christopher with his bare hands and then
the finale he dies and that would be the
worst glad all that will never happen
Tony is wearing loafers with no socks
and that is 100% a suit also I'm excited
to see how David chase wraps this show
up I'm sure the resolution will be
Rhianna ducks and ducks fly together
Birdman hello so you're not a great
actor who cares
you tower over these other theater
douchebags hello it's like whoa baby I
mean this cat is like Charles Bronson in
the Great Escape
[Music]
how you doing how you doing our
existence on this earth is a puzzle like
sands through the hourglass so are the
days of our lives